matin avec cette importante question en
tête mais comment est née l'univers
bonne nouvelle le satellite européen
planck parti il ya un an va nous aider à
y voir un peu plus clair
on se réjouit les frères bogdanoff aussi
pascal justice georges minois
tout ce que vous avez toujours voulu
savoir sur l'origine de l'univers mais
que vous avez peut-être train de ne pas
comprendre vous est racontée dans le
dernier livre des frères bogdanoff des
équations d'einstein au satellite
tout s'éclaire d'une lueur seles
découvre d'abord que l'univers a une
origine sur le papier grâce à des
équations d'einstein rappel était
absolument persuadé que l'univers et fx
est bien ce mathématicien extraordinaire
qu'est freeman démontre le contraire en
1921 c'est la première étape de la
naissance du big band et puis surtout on
va découvrir que ce big bang prédit par
friedman et bien il existe et on peut
l'observer
c'est hull qui en 1929 à être le premier
à mettre en évidence la fuite des
galaxies l'expansion de l'univers
en cette première moitié du 20e siècle
on scrute univers depuis la terre puis
on écoute en 1964 avec cette grande
antenne penzias et wilson ont entendu ou
de l'explosion originel qui a eu lieu il
y à 13 milliards 700 millions d'années
l aventure continue parce que en 1989 un
satellite va être lancé par george smoot
un physicien américain
il va être lancée avec pour but de
photographier pour la première fois le
fond diffus stone est en fait le
rayonnement fossile le big bang
et lorsqu'il découvre ses photos smoot
sera tellement ébloui qu'il va dire
c'est comme voir le visage de dieu et
c'est pourquoi nous avons repris ce
titre si fort c'est puissant pour notre
mur vingt ans après le satellite kobe de
george smoot voici plan véhiculée par
ariane 5 le satellite européen a quitté
la terre en mai 2009 planck a parcouru
plus d'un million de kilomètres pour se
positionner en un point où les forces
d'attraction de la terre et du soleil
s'équilibre planck va photographier le
ciel en tournant sur lui même
chaque prise de vue dure huit mois
coordinateur à l' agence spatiale
européenne jan tauber nous explique que
le rayonnement de la toute première
lumière de l'univers n'est pas la
brillance au centre de la photo
non cette brillance c'est le coeur de
notre galaxie l'éclat du big bang lui se
trouve dans la partie rouge et ce qui
l'intéresse c'est l'apparition de ces
petites tâches ce qui se passe c'est que
la lumière se libère de la matière cette
matière après que la lumière a été
libéré il on commence à se développer et
se transformer si vous voulez en des
étoiles des galaxies et des amas de
galaxies et toutes les structures que
nous voyons aujourd'hui toutes ces
petites tâches en devenir des étoiles
des galaxies des amateurs
- vous arriver je voudrais bien j'arrive
pas
d'autres photos seront prises par planck
avant que les scientifiques ne livrent
leurs conclusions en 2012 ce qui nous
laisse encore un peu de temps pour
actualiser nos connaissances vous iriez
bien aussi non